mais tout de suite direction blois et la
maison de la donne est donc ici à blois
on a le festival de la bande dessinée
on a également la mise la bande dessinée
oui donc qui est le prolongement en fait
du festival puisque le festival existe
depuis une trentaine d'années et puis
depuis 2015 une nouvelle structure la
maison de la bande dessinée qui est
d'abord un lieu d'exposition on peut
également suivre des cours et si pour le
grand public
alors ça c'est la deuxième fonction de
la maison de la bande dessinée
l'éducation à la bande dessinée pour les
amateurs pour les amateurs mais aussi
pour des semi-professionnels
enfin le troisième volet de la maison de
la bande dessinée c'est aussi la
création c'est à dire qu'on a un atelier
d'auteur des puits de la coédition parc
watine on conseille de commencer et
m'écoutent
voilà on proposa un joli petit programme
tout d'abord on va passer à l'atelier
d'auteur un hibou team y aller
illustratrice après je te propose de
rencontrer matip de landry qui est
médiatrice culturelle à la maison de la
bd et donc elle te proposera un cours
sur mesure avec de la bd numérique
et puis pour terminer de rencontrer
aussi le cours des enfants pour les 8-12
avec ambroise à les chinois on y
regarder on y font smart artistes
bonjour c'est la salle et smart artistes
ici bonjour à nice alors vous nous a
vivement conseillé de venir voir votre
travail
tu utilises quoi pour travailler tue à
la peinture au fusain maj ôta stylo bic
entre les mains la ccdh et croquis au
stylo bille way pour pour ce projet là
mais j'utilise aussi parfois la peinture
j'ai une dizaine d'albums à la peinture
vous faites à l'acrylique travaille
aussi en entrevue
l encre oui c'est vrai je l' ai alors à
celui-là ça ces manifs comme ça illustre
clairement en bichromie way en
partenariat avec la maison la bbc très
doux je trouve c'est très poétique quand
on utilise l'encré de chine
oui mais là c'était là c'était la
direction que je devais prendre une race
est dans l'imaginaire et dans la poésie
c'est compliqué d'adapter des
illustrations à un texte
c'est une aventure avec l'éditeur et
donc après moi j'essaie de m'imprégner
du texte
de proposer des choses de faire des
recherches merci à annie pour cette
entrée en la matière je pars maintenant
découvrir l'univers de mathilde voilà
par exemple ça c'est plus basse et plus
réaliste là on est plus sur douze et
s'indigne un peu j'adore ce que fait
matiz je mélange un peu laisse quelques
j'aime bien donc du côté demande bien si
tout ça tu le fais sur table tous
assurent way sur tablette
ce qui est bien ici c'est que finalement
tous les styles sont représentés à nice
j'ai vu travailler à l'encré de chine
vous l'avez vu et là on est en quête le
papier c'est ça la tablette
souvent je travaille uniquement sur
tablette même le crayonné je le fais
directement sur la tablette c'est un
gain de place déjà des médiatrices
culturelles ici est également
illustratrice sais je vais faire le lien
entre tout ce qui est création les
auteurs les planches etc et le public je
me montre un petit peu comment ce qu'on
décide sur une tablette
on a de la première étape c'est le sait
au crayon c'est vraiment croquis moi
j'adore faire vivre les storyboards donc
là je vais faire mon petit personnage
tout tu viens d'angoulême
tu as quitté la qualité de la bd pour
venir ici à brûler tout retrouver dans
l'univers de la bd mais tu étais tu as
fait tes études angoulême 1 ouais j'ai
fait j'ai passé 5 ans et demi à anglet
pour les écoles de bandes dessinées et
commentateurs ici la boire j'ai fait un
stage et je les fais et je suis resté
par partie donc si tu palier de thé de
patience et la médiatrice culturelle et
illustratrice de bande dessinée que je
veux faire de la bd c'est la semaine et
le transmettre aux gens donc moi ça
j'adore ça donc je vous parle des 5
prend forme je peux vous dire que ça va
très vite sous le style et de mathilde
il donc mathilde excès petite queue de
cheval là je trouve qu'elle ressemble un
peu la faute à me provoque depuis tout à
l'heure il a écouté cinq adolescents
qu'il arrive toujours avec mon sac à dos
qui va rentrer à l'intérieur d'une
dessinée de cloche j'adore je vais te
faire tester
là tu as une petite roue qui te permet
de choisir la couleur quelle couleur tu
veux prendre mon pull mais que c'est moi
comment va se terminer aujourd'hui
comment je m'habiller en rouge ça va
très bien ouais ap le rouge est un pion
rouge
et puis je vais te laisser la mort de
madeleine riffaud que je délimitent la
zone qui va être colorier des coloriages
donc ça va tout seul ça glisse très
facilement sur l'écran nous faut faire
attention
mince j'ai débordé la ligue 1 elle
contrôle z voilà les réflexes à
attention regardez la magie du style et
de la tablette numérique en un clic
je remplis ma zone trop fier
il faut quand même que je montre
résultat tu m'as offert tablettes avec
ou pas
merci d'avoir besoin mais tu reviens aux
tâches compte yeux je te fais des cours
particuliers c6 est pas tombée dans
l'oreille d'une sourde un tu vas venir
me voir arriver à blois là avec mon
petit sac à dos voilà comme ça là mais
fait également de la bd pas de programme
beaucoup ma tin après cette initiation
très sympathique au côté de mathilde
direction le conte d'ambroise avec mes
nouveaux camarades de classe de prépa
est décédé
c'est vrai bonjour bonjour
bonjour bonjour monsieur bonjour
ok je vais vous donner au choix trois
exercices je vais vous donner les
crayons et des feuilles comme d'habitude
après c'est qu'elles avaient toutes les
deux donc tu avais envie de suivre aussi
des cours de bandes dessinées oui
j'adore ça tombe bien vous avez un super
prof ambroise fait vrai ambroise du coup
à chaque fois que c'est lé début de
séance commence comme ça tu donnes une
thématique générale et après ses aveux
de laisser libre cours à leur
imagination alors en général ou régional
un petit m mais ça reste très très libre
quand même et parfois c'est complètement
bidon ça peut te un décor un personnage
importe quoi je les ai des dessus à
paris alors lâché à lui on est vraiment
dans le monde des super-héros en train
de constituer sa bande dessinée je vais
mettre à côté de toi écrite il ya toute
une histoire là
elle niera ça parle de quoi dans un
espèce de monstre du loch ness way qui
veut attaquer la supérette gelac la
supérette du lac dans une base
intergalactique
il y en a deux secondes content car le
méchant elle est en train d'attaquer le
lac
j'essaie de la wii salut coucou mes
bébés qu'on a la larme alerte revenir
mais je te laisse s'avancer sur ton
dessin monsieur oui qu'est-ce que je
peux faire
alors à ce qu'on pourrait faire là c'est
les bases pour faire un visage des cons
truit directement en gros ont fait de
cette forme là on peut dessiner le côté
du nez dessinée juste le bout ici moi je
conseille plutôt cela que ce coup là
c'est pas mal pour demeurer bas je m'y
attèle hockey est ce que j'apprenais et
après on voit pour mettre les cheveux
dans son regard est là et tout ça mais
déjà l'un construire comme ça suffit on
est souvent que la vérité sort de la
bouche des enfants
le la cus que tu portais cette fille
[Musique]
merci à ces passionnés de la bande
dessinée pour ce plongeon dans le
neuvième art des jolis moments que je
souhaite immortaliser sur mon blog
avant de reprendre la route
[Musique]